foreign
Peter is with us in Canada hi Peter
welcome to the Ramsey Show
thanks for taking my call sure what's up
um so I'm currently entering my third
year of University
I'm married
um me and my wife have been very
financially independent
um we're both in school we're both
foresee being able to pay off for our
school uh just through hard earned cash
while just doing summer jobs wonderful
um but uh we've been doing them we've
been kind of realizing you know that the
student loan rate in Canada we don't
have interest on our student loans we
don't start paying until
six months after graduate and so we were
wondering are we thinking about
maximizing out the student loans we can
take out and putting it aside in a
separate High interest savings account
uh maybe even in invest into some
short-term bonds and then when we
graduate uh take all that money out uh
pay off our student loans in full and
then you know keep the keep the money
that we made from from the interest my
question is uh what what I know that
you're very adamant about
staying out of debt if possible
not not impossible I'm just adamant
about staying out of debt period
right but let's go ahead how much are
you talking about doing how much money
uh me so about fifteen thousand dollars
uh a year for me and my wife so that's
about thirty thousand dollars each so
sixty thousand dollars
yeah okay and and the uh bond rate is
what
it's about five and a half percent okay
all right so three thousand bucks
um that's what you're gonna make per
year that's what you're gonna make three
thousand dollars and what's your degree
in
Finance
yeah okay
um
and you're in your third year of Finance
degree
no so I'm just doing Bachelor of
Commerce currently uh majoring at uh
majoring in finance yeah going in going
into my third
um have have you ever had a statistics
class yet
not yet not yet okay I can tell okay
um go ahead Dave
um so here's what you're missing
risk
the only way your program works is if
there is a zero risk scenario which does
not exist
okay
so the problem is you call the guy
that's been doing this for 35 years so
I've seen everybody do every possible
stupid butt thing they can do in their
lives or have horrible tragedies happen
to them in their lives that you have not
anticipated or
oh maybe the bond market has a problem
that's never happened of course that
happens all the time
and so maybe you don't make three
thousand
and uh maybe oh have you did you know
that bonds go down in value when
interest rates go up you know it's an
inverse relationship
yeah yeah
and so you're going to take out a sixty
thousand dollar loan with sixty thousand
dollars worth of bonds interest rates go
up now your bonds are worth fifty
thousand dollars but you have to repay
sixty thousand dollars
you know values go down when interest
rates go up it's an inverse relationship
with the modern Market to interest rate
somewhere in the rising interest rate
environment aren't we
is that that's called risk okay so your
plan is
um
not good it's left out key components
which makes it really really risky and
naive that's problem number one with it
problem number two with it is you are
trying to make money doing nothing
making money doing nothing usually will
cause you problems
so don't try to make money doing nothing
problem number three is I'm pretty sure
I'm not positive but I
just about positive that the government
of Canada did not come up with a student
loan program for Peter to invest in the
bond market
meaning that you're misusing These funds
which is not illegal but it is at a
minimum unethical or immoral I agree
with that
so
um lots of reasons Peter to not do this
lots of reasons you did not anticipate
risk
another way that you can if you're ever
faced with something like this again
that help you feel the risk is just take
your proposed scenario and multiply it
like 10 or 100x
and see if it doesn't make you want to
throw up a little bit that's so good
then you really see the gravity of it so
in other words what you do this with six
hundred thousand dollars if you could do
it would you do this with six million
dollars if you could do it oh no so now
you're starting to feel like oh God
something could go wrong well if
something could go wrong well dude
something could go wrong and let me just
tell you it's not something good it's
pretty likely to absolutely it's pretty
likely to so
um yeah it's just um and all for three
grand that's my thing it's not even a
lot of money go deliver some pizzas and
get you some three grand for a year yeah
I mean that's just not a lot yeah you
are playing with a barrel full of snakes
for three grand
hoping to not get bit so
um there's the problems with your theory
and because your theory is empty it's
missing entire sets of variables that
when implemented make this really
unattractive and you forgot the ethics
and the morals part of it too which will
also Lead You astray and get you into
problems so Dave that was good I I was
expecting you to really go into one of
your Dave modes well
you taught you taught the thing is I um
I I it wouldn't have been fair to him
that's true yeah no you caught it so he
had to uh because he doesn't know
and he didn't call up with an arrogance
he was asking an honest question and he
just didn't know so it wouldn't have
been fair to him to kill him
um as tempting as it might have been I
was I was I was giving you the energy
yeah I know you are you're I I felt it I
felt you aging me on it's almost as bad
as when Sharon does that but yeah oh my
gosh no I mean he's a he's a good guy he
just hadn't thought about some of the
stuff because he's young and I'm glad he
called in because I know a lot of people
have fooled around with that idea in
different types of way basically taking
debt to invest it so yeah so for those
of you over in the nerd side her head
are still spinning the reason I ask
about statistics class was not to be
sarcastic but um in Stat one the first
class you take they will teach you uh a
measure of risk called a beta and a beta
is the the distance between the hill and
the valley if you look at a graph and
it's going up and down like a mountain
in the valley the distance between the
bottom and the top is your beta okay so
and and so in an investment analysis a
beta is your measure of risk
and so for those of you out there doing
your Investments you'll see it actually
it's one of the people is you actually
do see it in the real world other than
stat class is with mutual funds so a A
in the in the United States the standard
and poor the S P 500 is the measure the
Baseline of the stock market it is a 1.0
beta so it's your Baseline okay so if
you have a mutual fund that has a 0.8
less than one that means it's less
volatile than the stock market if you
have a mutual fund for instance an
aggressive growth stock mutual fund
might have a 2.0 beta which means it's
twice as volatile as the s p Baseline
okay the standard poor Baseline so you
see it there but what happens is people
do not apply that type of mathematical
thinking and formula which that's an
actual math measure of risk no people
don't apply that to debt and see he left
he left risk out of his math formula
yeah he did so he's thinking okay I'm
going to make 3000 sixty thousand but I
did not adjust my returns for risk and
that's why I was asking about that
because you adjust it for risk and this
is really a a an egghead explanation of
why God says in the Bible that the
borrower is slave
to the lender slaves don't have choices
slaves are seldom generous
so slaves lose their personhood and this
is what happens when you step into the
Noose of debt because you haven't
measured risk adequately very good so
this is that you know you look at it
through a Biblical lens a spiritual lens
the lens of faith we can look at it
through the academic lens we can look at
it through Grandma's Common Sense
grandpa says Sean you bought that car
you did what that was my grandpa drove
up in a new Jaguar I was a millionaire
my grandpa looked at me like I'd lost my
mind he goes 10 years what's that car
going to be worth and I said not as much
and he said well I call my investments
things that go up
look at that Grandpa was right